Hello, I'm Natasha Bedingfield.
What's going on?
This is Drizzy Drake.
Hey, I'm Pat and I'm here with Jimmy and Scott and we're Train.
What's up? This is yours truly, Mike Posner wishing everyone a happy New Year.
Happy New Year to everyone.
Happy New Year everybody!
New Year's traditions?
As far as traditions go, I don't really have any actually.
I hang out with my friends and rage.
My New Year's tradition just usually involve drinking.
Not get too drunk.
That's quite a good tradition.
Trouble.
The next day, on New Year's Day, I always get a really big breakfast, American style.
Basically, trying to make the New Year better than the year before.
My New Year's tradition is to kiss every girl in the room.
Drink a lot, have fun and sing Auld Lang Syne.